welcome to this video playing fits T
from Australia let's see her play time
before I have three losses against the
sky with no score whatsoever thats it's
great i remember that i was very very
well in those put in those games came
the strange age shoreline of the green
thought so it's quite interesting to
play c6 is a good a good reply but it
has one particular merit it's not a very
Greenfeld ish sort of position it's very
static and in the scent and people who
played the green felt sometimes struggle
with those kind of static structures it
pretty much depends on the player it's
not like they're all one-trick ponies
but in general that's not it's not an
uncommon occurrence that they don't
handle these types of positions so well
I maybe night age 5 p.m. okay
okay i wonder if i should simply trade
everything off here and go for an
endgame like take here queen dee 5 the
queen bee five
Brooks III is this a threat yeah it is a
threat Queen d2 that's 90 form so Roxy
three Queenie 294 okay but I can I can
take let's try this now look c3 I can
play Queen d2
ok
hyf roots III Queen d2 should be okay so
let's um do this using using this H for
moving away maybeee 5 is a movie not
sure if I've this I didn't really think
about what is the point really
Roxy Roxy three on
not quite sure what the move is the
power to roots III is the threat yeah
but i can i can give the check i can
also pay Queen d2 I can castle okay
let's just castle now maybe if form and
take you on d5 or this first okay you
for ticks if I come on let's let's play
let's just play taking too much time
here
and I don't have anything direct yeah
that's quite remarkable it looks like
somewhat shaky position for black but I
don't see anything anything concrete
happening
check
not sure if this poem was done on
purpose or I mean tough position anyway
the bishop on d4 is worth an exchange
anyway check
going for Luke h3y a quickly decided by
him but it's it's clear that he has a
compensation further for the Queen the
bishop on d4 is very strong
yeah I'm not sure that I'm even better
relief because some black's pieces
coordinate very very well
exchanging one pair of rooks would
definitely help
check-check time warning yeah I think
everything this was was a good a good
idea it was tricky to play maybe you can
play b5 now I Queen B 6 was much more
natural
draw our third bit afraid that you will
pick up the pawns
game drama I'm not sure I mean I think I
can I absolutely cannot win but I can I
might as well lose the game maybe I'm
too negative about this but I I drew I
really don't see any sort of winning
idea maybe with better time and so on
but that was tricky he he really had a
good position after the the window of
the screen maybe I'm I made a mistake
here and I should have just taken taken
the exchange does this look tempting but
if you if you look at this black black
has a very very nice coordination with
the rukon c2 coming and so on why here
yeah the computer is giving like a very
big advantage yeah I'm not surprised
this is just a very well coordinated
position winning the Queen wasn't the
best really it was it was quite somehow
it's not it was quite a relief that i
got in this can not here at least i
should lose but i really should have
gone for for the chat we know the
exchange am taking and now maybe just
just this yeah i'm here why does better
somewhat the bishop is strong but it's
still an exchange brooksy for oxy one
hook c7 these kind of ideas or maybe
hear ya black ass has come has some
compensation that said that sets up this
but if anyone is better at certainly
white with the the possibility to enter
on the C file now there was was a very
very complicated game anyway I was a bit
surprised that here you for wasn't any
good it seems it just seemed very
natural to me to open up the center but
didn't really did really lead to too
much
now ya hear the problem was that rooks
III was threatened I could if I could
have gone here of course then e6 well I
mean here there is there is not much not
much happening check something like this
is just just equal Luke see one and
nothing nothing happening I wanted to
wanted to play it a bit more ambitiously
but really I thought that there might be
some some tricks or but there is nothing
this was mostly a blunder and that was
it was lucky that this was actually
working oh here this is interesting with
cream cakes ruki one is very nice
forward and this looks totally dangerous
but ends in an equal position funny
enough so e5 wasn't really great and he
had I thought actually f5 yeah and it is
strong that is the strongest I can go
here but it's there is no direct threat
or anything that I'm posing this is just
a super strong piece yeah it was a bit
bit too creative the c-4 idea here
should have conform normal continuation
alright thanks for watching